hey what's going on everybody i am dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message today is october 6 2021.
do me a favor share our videos subscribe
to our channel tap the notification bell
etc etc guys before we do anything else
i think we got three stories for you
today but before we do anything else
right before we started i just saw this
video on twitter and i just have to
share it with you this is rashida talib
you know this woman she is a member of
the squad she is a marxist she's an
anti-american activist i don't know how
she's in congress really just a truly
truly horrible woman but every now and
again they get to be fully exposed
on camera they forget that there's
cameras around them at all times and
listen to what she says
about masks this is just in the last
hour or
so so much for coming out again
greg's been out in all of our all of our
community
did you catch that there at the end as
she took off her mask to talk to the
person showing you that it's all theater
i'm only wearing this because there's a
republican tracker there
man she is an extraordinary liar and i
get it they lie to us about
absolutely everything but think about
how perverse what she's doing there is
so i'm wearing a mask because there's a
republican there so i know masks are
nonsense i wear it to fool
my idiot progressive bass who just likes
masks or they're afraid of everything or
we're just trying to manipulate them and
keep everybody in constant paralysis and
thinking that they're going to die and
everything else i'm only doing this
because of those mean republicans
you know meaning i know the masks are
nonsense i'm only doing it because
there's a republican there these people
are absolutely evil at what point is
this not evil it's not enough to just
say oh they're well intended and the
hotels made with good intentions or
they're nice people and they're just
confused or the science isn't settled no
she's evil she's evil actually she's
evil she's an evil c word there i know
if i say the c word i'm not you know
what i'm going to write it down
i'm going to write it down because if i
say the c word we're going to get
demonetized and crushed in the algorithm
am i right yeah so i just wrote down the
c word
you know what i'm going to show it to
you i'm going to show it to you too
because i'm pretty sure we won't get
demonetized if i didn't say it but i
come on
cat okay
she's an evil cat
because everybody hates cats they're
sitting there they're staring at you
they're gonna pounce on you scratch you
in the eye
you know cats are so evil that if you
they don't want pregnant women to touch
kitty litter did you know that that's an
actual thing and they say that somehow
if you live in a house or a small
apartment this was a big thing in new
york city years ago you live in a small
apartment with a cat with a kitty litter
the kitty litter releases something the
cat poop and the kitty litter actually
releases something that can make women
go insane that's an actual thing google
it that's a real thing anyway she's a
lying c word
awful what an awful human being
she knows the mask is [ __ ] they know
it's [ __ ] she's standing outside
there's unmasked people there masked
people and then she pulls it down to
tell either the reporter or whoever that
was
that that this is all nonsense i only do
it for theater so the republicans aren't
mean to me
god awful like when are we just enough
americans just going to say enough is
enough we are being governed by a bunch
of absolutely horrific people and get
some balls people and start standing up
against this abject nonsense actually
speaking of that i wish i could have
gone this morning but there was a huge
uh anti-vaxx mandate rally in beverly
hills uh right by where the old trump
rallies were that i went to which and
there were tons of people out there and
you're not gonna believe it they were
out there and it's 80 degrees and sunny
and there were american flags and they
were talking about freedom and the
constitution and good stuff like that
we're going to go to the next one i
obviously couldn't do it if i'm here
with you guys right now but these people
are evil so i just want to be very very
clear rashida talib you are an evil c
word cat nobody likes cats
we got three stories for you today uh
first off this joe biden fella he's part
of talib's crew right everyone thought
oh no no he's not a radical he'll stop
the squad he'll stop the progressives
the government won't be completely evil
america will be saved under joe biden 47
years in public office joe biden he'll
be different now
well we've got a whole bunch of videos
abiding from complete and utter babbling
to lying to
just more nonsense you'll see in just a
sec then the second story is about
facebook because yesterday was the big
hearing the whistleblower well it turns
out that the whistleblower and i was
hinting at this yesterday because it was
sort of unfolding at the very moment the
whistleblower is basically a left-wing
activist and it's becoming more and more
clear
and yesterday just watching a
whistleblower basically giving public
policy prescriptions basically being
like censor them censored them it's like
is that a whistleblower or an activist
well now we've got some evidence and
finally a shout out to our friends up in
the once free country to our north known
as canada uh alberta is shutting down
for thanksgiving they do a thanksgiving
a little earlier than our thanksgiving
here in america they're their own
country and they're entitled to their
own traditions uh and just awful
absolutely awful the the leadership up
in alberta is just well they're trying
to lock everybody down and limit the
amount of people it's just all the
[ __ ] that we were all dealing with a
year and a half ago here they're still
dealing with it in canada and i'm here
to save my canadian friends
okay let's just talk about joe biden
before we do anything so first off i get
it i get it we all know he's not right i
am not a doctor i don't want to say he
has something that i don't know that he
actually has so we're just going to call
it generic old person syndrome and the
only reason i am playing this clip is
because they refuse to show this on
mainstream media but we all know that
he's not going to make it for the four
years and at some point as i've been
saying i think it'll be barack obama
we'll be on an interview or something
and say oh you know joe's maybe lost a
step or two and that will allow that
will be the sort of trigger i hate the
word trigger but that will be the
trigger for the
media to suddenly be like starting
asking questions and then there'll be a
piece in the new york times joe biden
lost this step and then there'll be
something on cnn and all of the people
who have ignored this the entire time
because he's their guy will have gotten
the signal that you're allowed to talk
about something being wrong with joe
biden but if you don't think something's
wrong with joe biden watch this
parenthetically when you build a
charging station it's like back in the
day when my grandpop worked for the
mayoral canal company back in the
tournament in the 19 1920 in that area
they went from state to state convincing
people that they put allow them to put
20 000 gallons of gasoline under the
ground they didn't want them around
congratulations everybody that
apparently is the most powerful man on
earth well yesterday when we watched
that clip how many times did we watch a
connor and i was laughing hysterically i
actually i was about to be on newsmax
and i was laughing so hard that i was
crying i was i wasn't even sure if i was
going to be able to be on the appearance
but i wrote it down i wrote down what
joe biden said this is a day of pen and
paper for me
cat remember kat uh i wrote down what
joe biden said i'm going to read it to
you and because maybe maybe we're losing
something through the way joe biden said
it maybe he was just saying a little too
fast or something so i thought i'd say
it to you and and you tell me if this
makes sense
parenthetically when you build a jargy
stations like back in the day when my
grandpop worked for the merrell cologne
back in the turn of the
19 19 in that area they [ __ ]
in that area they went to state to state
convincing people that a lot of them put
20 000 gallons of gasoline underground
they didn't want them around
i feel like there's a rapper that has
used that that doesn't that sound like
something like that's nicki minaj
couldn't you see her doing the the rap
is that what they do they do they spin a
little diddly like that's what she'd do
the merrell cologne station i like that
one and the no the merrell cologne back
in the turn of the what the jargy
stations which i think isn't that where
luke skywalker was going on tatooine
didn't he have to pick up the power
convert converters oh that toshi station
sorry that was tashi station not jargy
stations all right so look the man's not
well fine so be it uh but let's uh let
go a little bit further let's stick to
policy dave don't hit the low-hanging
fruit stick to policy here's joe biden
who as you remember when he was elected
said that we'd be healing we'd come
together as a nation we're all one we're
good we love each other
joe biden meteor is
headed to crash into our economy
democrats are willing to do all the work
stopping it
republicans just have to let us do our
job
just get out of the way
if you don't want to help save the
country get out of the way
so you don't destroy it
get out of the way if you don't want to
help us save the country so you don't
destroy it man
bad man you're a bad bad man and i get
it you're not really president i get it
we're all pretending you're president
but you're not
and you're just repeating the nonsense
that they put in front of you and
usually doing it pretty poorly the idea
that the republicans don't want to save
the country because the republicans are
doing something like believing in math
when it comes to 3.5 trillion or because
they don't believe the same thing as you
when it's related to abortion or climate
change climate change that the policy
prescriptions are a little bit different
than what you might want and i'm not
even sitting here telling you that the
republicans are that great as i've been
saying for a while you don't have to be
a republican i don't consider myself a
republican a republican's a political
party i'm more into ideas i like
ideology so my ideas now fit more within
i would say a wide conservative set of
ideas but a political party you could be
a polit in the political party or not
but when he's saying that they want to
basically in essence destroy the country
that's what he's saying because they
have a difference of opinion when it's
fairly obvious
i mean i guess this is a little ironic
but it's fairly obvious that he and the
democrats are the ones that want to
destroy the country right crazy
inflation right now
thousands of people pouring through our
borders i just saw this morning that
more people died in 2021 because of
kovid than in 2020.
can we impeach this fool i mean what are
we really talking about here he's
actively destroyed we're having supply
chain issues everyone knows about that
right when was the last time anyone any
of you tried to buy something like like
something that you have to that they
have to build like go buy a couch like
go to west elm or creighton barrel or
wherever you buy a couch we were trying
to buy a new couch most couches you used
to be able to get a couch and say a week
a couple days right maybe two weeks you
want that special fabric literally all
the couches right now go to west elms
cb2 crate and barrel all the basic
places one would buy a couch everything
is like march or april if you try to buy
a couch right now so joe biden is in
effect destroying the country joe biden
is bringing in critical race theory joe
biden is ushering in social justice and
all of this nonsense but if the
republicans don't do what i want if they
don't give me enough money i don't have
enough money i want your money and if
you don't give us enough of your money
then you want to destroy the country
just like those evil republicans now of
course the irony is as i always say it's
not about how much money the government
takes in it's that the government is
always wasting money and if you don't
believe me oh lord we got a segment for
you right here this is former border
patrol chief rodney scott he's on fox
news talking to bret bear and
he's talking about what happened with
the border wall in the south and listen
to the amount of money we now waste to
do absolutely nothing
talk about the border wall what were the
instructions
after the transition of administrations
when it came to the wall
so presidential proclamation came out
and now it's a 60-day pause that
publicly available we're supposed to do
an in-depth study and then come up with
a plan going forward as border patrol
did its part everything that was done
within about two weeks
several briefings later there really
hadn't not been any decisions made it
went well beyond the 60 days
many of those projects today are just
still on hold so we're paying
contractors
for a while it was almost 5 million a
day between dod and dhs just to not to
not build the border wall there's
5 million a day to not build the wall to
not build even though they have all the
stuff they have there are stacks and
stacks of border wall
panels there's hundreds of miles of
fiber optic cabling uh there's hundreds
of of cameras that we're being in
5 million a day to do nothing
to do jack [ __ ]
that is what our government is paying
contractors they've got all the stuff
right they got the hammers they got the
nails little plasterboard
it's all there we are paying these
people 5 million a day to do nothing but
you know if you don't give joe biden
more of your money you're a bad
person do you get it yet man america is
under attack i really believe that we we
are under attack i don't know exactly
what it is from this compilation of
media and the democrats and big tech and
probably china and like there's some
evil thing and it's sitting there and we
can all see it but we don't have all of
the pieces that we can put together in
the puzzle but we are just fully under
attack actually i was doing cardio this
morning and there's a recut of rocky iv
coming out you know rocky versus drago
and rocky goes and he fights drago on
christmas day in moscow he's wearing the
american flag shorts and i was like man
that's the america that i want to live
in again i remember that america and we
better find some people who are willing
to stand up for that america and find
that spirit again because
we're in trouble we are in trouble we
are being led by incompetent liars liars
like rashida talib and incompetent
people like joe biden we have a media
that runs cover for them for everything
big tech that fuels the whole thing
we'll get to more on that in just a sec
and and we got work to do
let's talk about raycon guys you know
there's so much going on in the world
and the truth uh whether it's the stuff
you're excited about like pumpkin spice
products it is that time of the year or
stuff you'd rather not think about like
anything happening in the news
and thanks for watching you can't always
control the vibes out there but you can
always control the vibes in your head
with a pair of raycon wireless earbuds
in your ears whether i use them to pump
up wind down work or work out raycons
are my go-to for on-the-go audio and in
the new everyday ear and the new
everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever with an improved rubber
oil look and feel and optimize gel tips
for the perfect in-ear fit these are
impressive before you even start
listening you get three new sound
profiles to make sure everything you're
listening to sounds it's best with just
the right amount of bass i like pure
mode which is best for podcasts and
instrumental music you know i like that
chill channel on spotify there's also an
all new awareness mode for when you need
to listen to your surroundings instead
raycons offer eight hours of play time
and a 32 hour battery life there's also
a built-in mic and you can take calls on
your earbuds at the press of a button
raycon start at half the price of other
premium audio brands and come with a 45
day happiness guarantee right now reuben
report listeners can get 15 percent off
their raycon order at buyracon.com
reuben that's by raycon dot com slash
reuben to save 15 percent off raycons by
raycon r-a-y-c-o-n.com
reuben all right let's talk about
facebook because during the show
yesterday there was this capitol hill
hearing we had a facebook whistleblower
and as i said yesterday it kind of
sounded good she was saying they're
doing all sorts of things they're
manipulating us in all sorts of ways and
they're making us all angry and western
civilization is collapsing because of
the like button and all that stuff and
it was a bunch of stuff that we kind of
knew and we all sort of can see and we
know this stuff isn't making us happy
like we open apps and we're all angrier
than before like something ain't right
we all kind of know that
but then the hearing started taking a
turn because she suddenly started
prescribing things for the government to
do and that doesn't really sound like a
whistleblower whistleblower would be
like
here's a bunch of info uh they're up to
bad stuff that mean mark zuckerberg and
those big tech guys uh here's the stuff
i'm at a hearing but suddenly she
started saying but this is what you got
to do about it that's a very different
thing well now the story's starting to
change first we've got a little bit of
video of francis is her name francis
hagen is that right francis hogan from
the hearing yesterday
facebook has demonstrated they cannot
act independently facebook over and over
again has shown it uses profit over
safety it is subsidizing is paying for
its profits with our safety i'm hoping
that this will have had a big enough
impact on the world that they get the
fortitude and the motivation to actually
go put those regulations into place
okay obviously that wasn't from the
hearing that was from uh 60 minutes i
believe on sunday night
okay so you can see see she's sort of
saying there's some bad stuff here and
maybe there's some ways we can deal with
it all right so again it doesn't sound
like that awful it's a little weird
whatever now we've got some info from
the daily wire here on uh on haagen
hagen suggested that congress could make
facebook liable for promoting content
based on engagement rather than on
accuracy or any number of factors so
that's just her opinion on what maybe
facebook or what the government in
essence could do hoggin quote has a
record of donations to far left
democrats and a history of raising
issues about purported bias while at
previous employers she is working with
democrat operatives to roll out her
complaint and has the same lawyers as
the anonymous ukraine whistleblower
whose allegations led to donald trump's
impeachment but who reportedly turned
out to be then vice president joe
biden's top advisor in the country okay
now this is starting to get a little
weird the daily wire continues she's
also represented by a company called
bryce and gillette helmed by a raft of
democratic operatives who are providing
hoggin with strategic communications
guidance and helping run what one
republican called an incredibly well
orchestrated communications campaign the
free beacon reported burton is on the
board for the center of humane
technology which has waged a policy war
with facebook white house press
secretary jen saki worked at one point
with bryce and gillette with the center
for humane technology as one of her
clients uh okay so this is sort of
interesting we're getting a sense here
that maybe she is not exactly just some
average employee at facebook who had
some concerns and by the way when you
suddenly end up on 60 minutes a few days
after like these things don't happen
by happenstance you know like the way
the industry works if you're gonna get
on these tv shows there are publicists
involved right like i had a book out
like publicists get you on tv shows or
can't get you on tv shows for example
when my book came out i was able to get
on every fox show i was able to get on
every sort of center right thing but my
publicist at penguin the biggest
book publisher out there could not get
me on any cnn or msnbc shows because the
things that i talk about are against the
narrative that they want out there i'm
using that as an example because she
suddenly she goes okay facebook is bad
government better get involved and then
next thing you know she's on
a major news magazine show 60 minutes
and it's like oh so what what narrative
right like i know i know you guys get it
but this is the idea that we've got to
get across to our friends who are
confused about why we are on this slow
descent to hell the mainstream machine
crafts a narrative very carefully this
is how they launder the lies so she says
something at a hearing right then
it kind of works it way up its way up to
60 minutes it becomes sort of mainstream
zeitgeist then we get more politicians
suddenly saying okay we should censor
these things and of course the irony is
i'm not sitting here telling you that
facebook and twitter and youtube and the
rest of them are so great they're pretty
awful
they're pretty awful imagine if you had
a problem with your gmail account is
there anyone you could get on the phone
right absolutely not twitter banned me
back in july for saying that vaccine
mandates were coming okay these are
horrible companies and at some level i
pity them because they became too big
and they're run by leftist incompetent
morons because they believe more in
diversity than truth and that is going
to create a situation where you're going
to have a lot of bad things happening
and a bunch of people at your companies
who don't know what to do
but none of that is an excuse to them be
like okay government only if the
government could now censor facebook
more would be the answer but that's what
the machine wants the machine wants more
censorship
on these platforms and that's why i've
been saying for a while we have to be
careful what we ask for section 230 that
offers these big tech platforms
protections so that they can't be sued
for the content that goes on their
platforms once you revoke that which i
understand the inclination to revoke it
okay we're going to revoke that they
don't deserve any protections but then
what will they do they will suddenly be
like oh we have to censor more stuff
because we don't want to end up in
lawsuits that's why this whole thing is
so freaking messy well mark zuckerberg
who is the chief cylon droid over at uh
facebook he responded
to some of the comments made during the
hearing yesterday this is from the hill
mark zuckerberg responded to testimony a
facebook whistleblower gave to congress
on tuesday if we didn't care about
fighting harmful content then why would
we employ so many more people dedicated
to this than any other company in our
space even ones larger than us i don't
know what companies larger than facebook
but okay if we wanted to hide our
results why would we have established an
industry-leading standard for
transparency and reporting on what we're
doing he went on to say a bunch of other
things like that basically like we're
doing everything we can
and believe it or not guys i have some
sympathy for him as i just implied like
he's
trying to run this massive company that
became way bigger than everything he
became a gajillionaire for it like he
lives a life that is unimaginable to to
normal people okay um they're trying
perhaps
like let's not attack his atten
intentions for a second let's let's give
we'll do two things mark zuckerberg the
best version of it is that he's got this
company he had no idea how powerful it
was going to come the amount of
influence it could have over things and
then they see all sorts of hate they see
they see death threats they see child
porn god knows what evil stuff exists
there they try to manage it to some
level let's let's say that's the best
version of this they're trying to manage
it they're trying to make sure that
people aren't endlessly being doxxed and
assaulted and all of that stuff so
that's one version of it the other
version of it is that you get a bunch of
activists that work at these companies
and you bring in diversity and inclusion
departments and hr departments that will
tell you that half the country is nazis
and trump was evil and all these things
so the people the engineers the people
that are writing the policies and all of
that they are probably doing all sorts
of things that maybe zuckerberg doesn't
even know about it's a little bit like
remember the movie independence day and
what was the line when when the
president said what do you mean you've
had aliens in the basement for 30 years
and i didn't know about it and they say
plausible deniability right well mr
president plausible deniability they
wanted the president to be able to go
out there and if they said hey president
what was his name the president in uh
independence day if they were like uh mr
president you know there's aliens in the
basement over there in nevada and he
could say no there aren't and it would
be plausible deniability he wouldn't be
lying because he didn't know about it so
i think there's some uh there's a little
bit of that that they that zuckerberg
doesn't know certain things and by the
way the company is so freaking huge that
i wouldn't blame him the president of
independence day by the way was thomas j
whitmore played by bill
not bill belichick bill paxton bill
pullman bill pullman there you go people
anyway
so i don't know exactly how evil
facebook is but i know the government's
evil and i know that the more the
government gets involved the more they
will suppress thought we have this last
little bit of a window doesn't it feel
like this to cap this segment doesn't it
feel like this we've had this this
internet thing and this social media
thing for like 20 years and it was kind
of fun and great and cool and oh my god
look at the what my friend is eating and
all of those things and it was kind of
good and great and then it became sort
of horrible and mean and everybody
hating each other then politics got
infected with everything then they
started censoring more and more and now
it feels like we're in the last leg
of the golden age of the internet the
golden age of the internet's probably
passed us already but we're in the last
leg of what will be a free internet and
maybe it's long gone already and it's
just like a few of us still remain
because it would be too obvious to get
rid of everybody else but i sense we're
just in that last few steps here before
they do something whether that's an
internet kill switch or they start
you know just banning more sites or they
blow up more things like they did to
parlor or everything else
so well you know what i would say join
me at reubenreport.locals.com i was not
trying to make this a commercial but
that's where i'll be when they kick me
off everything else and uh and we can
chat there so it's very lovely uh all
right let's talk about canada for a
minute canada's become a huge mess you
know australia seems to be like the the
coveted mess beyond imagination i mean
they've got troops in the streets it's
actually just completely insane what's
going on in australia we've talked about
a little bit on this show you don't see
any of it on mainstream because they
don't want you to know that other
countries are even more draconian than
us because it might wake us up to what
could be coming for us right so you
never see it on cnn or anywhere else
obviously
you know just literally people walking
their dogs and being assaulted by police
officers old women being choked in the
name of health i mean this is literally
what's going on in australia but canada
has also gone into just
borderline police state at this point
if you want a little more info on this
you should watch our friday panel show
from two weeks ago we had ezra levant
from the rebel and lauren chen and who
else was on there oh and viva fry of
course
who at the time was running for a seat
in parliament in any event it's a mess
it's a freaking mess up there they're
closing churches they're not letting
people out they have
their they have troops on the streets
and they're locking people down i mean
the whole thing it's all there and the
video is out there online for now uh
here is video of alberta premier jason
kenny
talking about restrictions for canadian
thanksgiving
this weekend of course is thanksgiving a
time when family and friends gather
so my message is simple
please follow the rules that are in
place
to be blunt
no indoor social gatherings are
permitted outside of a household for
people who are unvaccinated for those
who are vaccinated indoor social
gatherings are limited to two households
for up to 10 people
who are age 12 or older
we are also lowering the maximum number
of people permitted to participate in
outdoor social gatherings from 200 to
20.
all right so i'm not going to sit here
and tell you that i have a tremendous
amount of knowledge about jason kenny
but if you want to pretend that that
dirt bag isn't going to violate his own
edicts uh you can but he obviously will
and i'm sure he does and i'm sure he's
getting together with plenty of people
and i'm sure they're not wearing masks
and he knows that it's all nonsense
interestingly there he said please
follow the rules so first it's nice to
say please right you got to teach the
young people you should say please be
respectful but or what
i didn't get to the or what part are you
going to start arresting people who dare
have canadian thanksgiving with 11
adults
or nine adults and three children above
12
and what happened to two weeks to
flatten the curve and what right do you
have to tell people how many people they
can get together with and what right do
you have to demand that anyone who's
hosting thanksgiving at their house
ask anyone else what their medical
status is
we have completely folks completely
outsourced our logic and our reason
and our our defense of privacy and your
ability to make decisions for yourself i
i just i'm i'm absolutely shocked uh
calgary's in alberta right can you
confirm that i'm 99 percent sure it is
that this is western canada if i'm not
mistaken can i get in
uh because if if it is in
alberta i'm pretty sure it is calgary's
in alberta um it is yeah um i've been to
calgary a few times um and twice we went
there with the jordan peterson tour and
they were two of the 10 best shows that
we did this was such a group of fun
loving freedom loving people the crowds
were nuts like the crowds actually the
ovations were huge it was like a running
joke about like i i could barely talk
because the crowds were screaming and i
was doing a ton of crowd work like
that's i think the spirit of of calgary
like western canada it's a little freer
there we like our freedom we have more
space we don't like the government
involved in everything it's not like
eastern canada right like i think that's
the spirit of western canada horse
country the tundra all of the stuff but
what is happening what is absolutely
happening well now
jason kenny the alberta premiere he's
also going to pay off if you haven't got
the vaccine the delta variant of covet
19
is causing concerning rises and
hospitalizations in our province
vaccinations have stalled in alberta and
to change that anyone who gets the shot
in the coming days now gets a bonus if
you just haven't gotten around to it for
the love of god please get vaccinated
now
and if you do we will now pay you a
hundred dollars
a hundred dollars you mean i've been
listening to the news for all of these
months i've made decisions on my own i
maybe work at home and i don't go out
that much or i'm young and healthy
you're gonna give me a hundred dollars
you're saying i could get call of duty
and and uh well that's about 60 what can
i get for 40 bucks what are people what
are the young people buying for 40
dollars i could get some soda pop and
you know some chips
like they're how does anyone believe any
of these people at this point
and and the bigger issue is these your
own your medical choices guys have
nothing to do with the government do
what is right
for yourself do what is right
for yourself uh and i think that you
have a better chance of surviving and
doing something that is that is
human that is the most
like special human thing that we got
which is thinking for yourself making
decisions that are right for you rather
than listening to jason kenny tell you
how many people you can have over for
thanksgiving and then if you behave the
way he wants he'll give you a hundred
dollars as if it's his money but it's
just money that they took from you guys
in the first place and then they give
you back i guess well a hundred dollars
forget the video games it's canada you
get a whole bunch of poutine right you
get a lot of poutine it's a gravy that
they put on french fries
i'm american
we like ketchup okay i know some people
put it in mayo it's disgusting but in
canada they put poutine
all over everything
so congratulations canadians get
injected
forcibly by the government and get a
hundred dollars worth of poutine
there you go guys part two of my
interview with blake masters who's
running for senator in arizona who
worked with peter thiel on zero to one
which is that's it the light blue book
right over there over my shoulder
who's a really interesting guy comes
from the tech world doesn't want the
government to solve all of arizonan's
problems
uh part two is up right now the full
thing is up uh at
reubenreport.locals.com i'm interviewing
rand paul later today right we're doing
a quick interview with probably like 15
20 minutes just a quick hit to catch up
on all the covid craziness and the
budget stuff and all of all of the
nonsense that we've talked about today
uh that'll be up tomorrow and if you
want to chat if you want to see what i'm
eating and all kinds of other stuff
reubenreport.locals.com
i enjoyed this show i'm going to say
top 10 show
you
top 10
top 10.
sure i signed their checks but you know
still
all right guys that's it i'll see you
tomorrow